I am a neurosurgeon and I'm here to tell
you today that people like me need your
help and in a few moments I will tell
you how but first let me start off by
telling you about the patient of mine
this was a woman in her 50s she was in
generally good shape but she had been in
and out of hospital a few times due to
curative breast cancer treatment now she
had gotten a prolapse from a cervical
disc giving her radiating pain of a
tense kind out into the right arm
looking at her MRI before the
consultation and decided to suggest an
operation now neck operations like these
are standardized and they're quick but
they carry a certain risk they make an
incision right here and it is sacked
carefully past the trachea there so
focus and you try not to cut into the
internal carotid artery then you bring
in the microscope and you carefully
remove the disc and the prolapse in the
nerve root canal without damaging the
cord and the nerve root lying only
millimeters underneath a worst-case
scenario is the damage to the cord which
can result in paralysis from the way
from the neck down explaining this to
the patient she felt silent and after a
few moments she uttered a few very
decisive words for me and for her doctor
is this really necessary and you know
what I realized right there and then it
was not in facts when I get patients
like this woman I tend to advise not to
operate so what made me do it this time
well you see this prolapse was so
delicate I could practically see myself
pulling it out of the runner root canal
before she entered the consultation room
I have to admit it I wanted to operator
I'd love to operator operating like is
this after all the most fun part of my
job
I think you can relate to this feeling
my architect neighbor says he loves to
just sit and draw and design houses he'd
rather do that all day then talk to the
person the clients paying for the house
and I might even give in restrictions on
what to do
but like every architect every surgeon
needs to look the patient in the eye and
together with the patient they need to
decide on what is best for the person
having the operation and that might
sound easy but let's look at some
statistics the tonsils are the two lumps
in the back of your throats they can be
removed surgically and that's called a
tonsillectomy this chart shows the
operation rate of tonsillectomies in
Norway in different regions what might
strike you is that there is twice the
chance that your kid because this is
from children will get the tonsillectomy
in Finnmark and in Trondheim the
indication in both regions are the same
there should be no difference at risk
here's another chart the meniscus have
stabilised the knee and can be torn or
fragmented acutely typically during
sports like soccer what you see here is
the operation rate on this for this
condition and you see that the operation
rate in murder room stall is five times
the operation rate in Stavanger five
times how can this be the soccer players
in the room stopped playing more dirty
than elsewhere in the country probably
not I've added some information now what
you see now is the procedures performed
in public hospitals a light blue the one
in private clinics is bright green there
is a lot activity on in the private
clinics in the room so isn't there what
does this indicate possible economic
motivation to treat the patients and
there's more recent research has shown
that the difference of treatment effect
between regular physical therapy and
operations for the knee there is no
difference meaning that most
the procedures performed on the chart
I just shown could have been avoided
even in Stavanger so what am I trying to
tell you here even though most
indications for treatments in the world
are standardized there is a lot of
unnecessary variation of treatment
decisions especially in the Western
world some people are not getting the
treatment that they need
but an even greater portion of you are
being over treated doctor is this really
necessary
I've only heard that question once in my
career my colleagues say they never
heard these words from a patient's aunt
eternity all the way around how often do
you think you'll get a no from a doctor
if you ask such the questions
researchers have investigated this and
they come up with about the same no rate
wherever they go and that is 30 percent
meaning 3 out of 10 times your doctor
prescribes or suggests something that is
completely unnecessary and you know what
they claim the reason for this is
patient pressure in other words you you
want something to be done a friend of
mine came to me for medical advice this
is the sporty guy do a lot of
cross-country skiing in the winter time
he runs in the summertime and this time
he had gotten a bad backache whenever he
went jogging so much that he had to stop
doing it I did an examination I
questioned him thoroughly
what I found out is that he probably had
a degenerated this in the lower part
with spine whenever he got strained it
hurt it already taken up swimming
instead of jogging there was really
nothing to do so I told him you need to
be more selective when it comes to
training some activities are good for
you some are not his reply was I want an
MRI on my back
why do you want an MRI I can get it for
free through my insurance at work come
on I said here also throw my friend
that's not a real reason well I think
it's going to be good to see how bad it
looks back there
when did you start interpreting MRI
scans I said trust me on this you're not
gonna need the scan well he said and
after a while he continued it could be
cancer he got the scan obviously and
Teresa insurance at work he got to see
one of my colleagues at work telling him
about the degenerative discs that there
was nothing to do at his she should keep
on swimming and quit the job after a
while I met him again and he said at
least now I know what this is but let me
ask you a question what if all of you in
this room with the same symptoms had an
MRI and what if all the people in Norway
had an MRI due to occasional back pain
the waiting list for an MRI would
quadruple maybe even more and you would
all take the spots on that list from
someone who really had cancer so a good
doctor sometimes says no but the
sensible patient also turned down
sometimes an opportunity to get
diagnosed or treated doctor is this
really necessary I know this can be a
difficult question to ask in fact if you
go back 50 years this was even
considered rude if the doctor had
decided what to do with you that's what
you did a colleague of mine now a
general practitioner was sent away on a
tuberculosis sanatorium as a little girl
for six months it was a terrible trauma
for her she later found out as a grownup
that her tests on tuberculosis had been
negative
all along the doctor has sent her away
on nothing but wrong suspicions no one
had dared or even considered
confronting him about it not even her
parents today
the Norwegian Health Minister talks
about the patient's health care service
the patient's is supposed to get advice
from the doctor about what to do
this is great progress but it also put
more responsibility on you you need to
get in the front seat with your doctor
and start sharing decisions on where to
go so the next time you're in the
doctor's office I want you to ask doctor
is this really necessary
and in my female patients case the
answer will be no but an operation could
also be justified so doctors what are
the risks attached to this operation
well five to ten percent of patients
will have worsening of pain symptoms one
to three percent of patients will have
an infection in the wound or even every
hamrick that might end up in a rio
pression 0.5% of patients also
experience permanent hoarseness and a
few but still a few will experience
reduced function in the arm or even nice
doctor are there other options yes rest
and physical therapy over some time
might get you perfectly well and what
happens if I don't do anything it's not
recommended but even then there's a
slight chance that you will get well for
questions simple questions consider them
your new toolbox to help us is this
really necessary
what are the risks are there other
options and what happens if I don't do
anything ask them when your doctor wants
to send you to an MRI when it prescribes
antibiotics or suggests an operation
what we know from research is that one
out of five of you 20% will change your
opinion on what to do
and by doing that you will not only have
made your life
a lot easier and probably even better
that the whole healthcare sector will
have benefited from your decision thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]